uh
typically like say i'm just here for you
but typically i'm uh
typically i'm here from about 10 30 or
11 in the morning until
three or four or five okay and it kind
of depends on who's uh
some days i come down here and it's
magic and i was like oh my god that was
a great one that was a great one
another days i come down here it's like
that that's a whole day wasted yeah with
nothing
nothing i'm going to use i just throw
out i throw out everything i accept you
make money off youtube like well i just
i just
monetized just a couple weeks ago and i
haven't made a penny yet yeah but i'd
really like to travel for this
yeah that's my number one goal okay like
in america or go to
just america i think yeah because to
travel all over the world with great
what could you do
they get so expensive and time consuming
that would just be hard to do this i'm
one guy
you see what my operation yeah people
will make comments on youtube going
tell your team to do it what [ __ ]
team you're looking at my team
that saves the guys yeah those guys just
want money from so that's my team
yeah so there is no team um but if i
start making money on youtube i would
pay an editor i would pay
somebody to help me with the donation
campaigns which is really
yeah bro it's the hardest part of what i
do that's why i don't do a lot of them
because yeah
every time i do one i always regret it
every day that it's
active except for jerry what i'm doing
for jerry right now he's cool
he's he's i could do a donation campaign
for guys like jerry all day long
this guy gets shot in the face oh jerry
i've seen him i think i've seen him once
yeah this guy's i watched that one too
that was amazing yeah he's an amazing
dude
and he's he's he's very likable i mean
so like all the
inside the dream center we have like
short-term missionaries come so people
come to a weekend
i've lived like tens of 50 days and i'm
like don't come down here thinking that
it's all like it's all about them like
people sometimes will teach you things
and like tell you things where you walk
away and you're like
well i think that person did more for me
than what like guys like jerry you can
see he's one of those guys like with the
wisdom he's just like
you know you're like wow yeah you think
you're gonna save yeah then
he ends up saving you you're like wow
yeah
yeah definitely no it's interesting how
all these dynamics of human interaction
are yeah
are so interesting all right so hayden
uh
so you work at a place called the dream
center yes so you're from australia from
australia sydney yeah and you're
fairly new here you've been here how
long 15 months about yeah
so january 2018. and you're working
primarily with people from skid row that
are fighting
addiction issues yes i've been coming to
skid row like a couple times a week for
over a year now yeah yeah yeah and
tell me like you've seen some of the
videos on my channel
yeah you contacted me and that's why
we're here but
what have you what have you learned from
from your time with all these people
what have i learned i mean what what i
mean what what was the most
misunderstood thing
they're not people so like these are
people who
were babies with children who had a you
know a childhood who had dreams who had
goals and stuff and you know
give or take with what's happened in
their life they've had a few bad
you know some people have been dealt a
rougher you know
hand of cards i guess you'd say on what
their life has been thing but
i think they just yeah they're people
they grew up you know they played
people played sport they went to high
school they did things like that so i
think the thing is to forget of
because of the condition they can get in
or where they're at when you see them
you forget that
hey this person wasn't here he hasn't
been here this whole life
so i think one thing is just trying to
find their story and whether they've
been here for
one month or 10 years find out what do
you actually want to do with your life
and how
how can we help them or how how are they
going to get out of here which i think
is
that's the big question with the housing
in la and the government and how it all
kind of works with that
have you seen successful stories where
people as well i've had people that
i've prayed for who have gotten housing
and then
with people not a lot of people having
having phones i haven't heard from them
but i've just heard
how they left they got out of here and
they got housing and things like that so
there are as far as successful stories i
haven't been in touch with many because
once they get out of here they kind of
just disappear i've had a few like stray
phone calls from odd numbers which is
people saying that they got out of there
and they're in
different areas and stuff but yeah there
are yeah there are
success stories like it's not a lot it's
not always all bad yeah
yeah so what do you guys do you come
down here and
yeah so we come down uh tuesday thursday
friday night saturday and then sunday
and sometimes
wednesday friday mornings depending on
how many people we have so and what do
you guys do
basically the dream center is not we're
not here to feed as much as we're here
to like
have conversations with these people and
with us being a faith-based organization
we're trying to help people get out of
here and come to the dream center i
think
right now we have a hundred and it might
be 150 100
we can house up to 150 men in the men's
discipleship program
and in the women's one i think we can
house up to
i'd say 40 or 50 50 something like that
i'm not sure on the numbers
but we're trying to get people into the
program that we have so the program we
have
is a year-long life recovery program so
they come in all their food clothing how
you know taken care of it's a
residential live-in program so it's not
it's not a shelter it's not they come in
they sleep and then they can leave
during the day
they're there they have a schedule and
that's kind of yeah that's part of the
yeah it needs to be that way it does
because these people need to get
structured back in their lives we're
talking about people here who haven't
probably had to answer to anyone in
10 years i've heard from several of the
addicts who've who've had some success
in the past but they relapse now
but they even said that the only way
that recovery rehab's ever going to work
is if i just commit to a full year
or more yeah so our program once they do
the year
they can apply for a second year and
then they can apply for a third year so
our program isn't
do the year and then you know great job
and this is
what does it cost or is it three years
free or free of cost first year second
year third year so the dream center is
uh
self-funded so it runs on donations yeah
from
other churches from people who donate
and things like that but
yeah it's i work in the program now so i
do the first
one to two weeks so when people come in
off the streets and
we have people coming in with just the
clothes on that they're wearing and
they come in you know they kind of have
a week or two to detox if they're
coming off alcohol or crystal meth or
heroin or whatever some guys just come
in because
they just you know divorce is common
like things like that so yeah
yeah it's very common and then after the
first two weeks they move into an
orientation phase which is four weeks
and then
basically the first month is like easing
them into it and then after that
they start the real phase which is level
one which is three months and then level
two
level three level four and then they
graduate so yeah and then they get
their job around the dream center so you
could be in the kitchen you could be
construction
so it's giving them practical training
them and how to do
practical stuff something like keeping
them busy you know it's actually
teaching them a skill
so once they do get out of here they
said well for nine months i did
such and such oh yeah i've seen so many
comments on some of the addiction
videos yeah that i put on my channel
that say well
why don't you just walk this person over
to rehab and get them all better and
everything will be perfect after that
yeah it's uh
what what what would you say leading the
horse to the water but you can't get it
to drink like i heard somebody somebody
that
is in your line of work say uh
i thought this was a great thing they
said yeah if an addict wants to quit
nobody can stop them yeah but if an
addict doesn't want to quit
nobody can make them no yeah exactly and
it's like
guys will come in i don't do the
interview with them but straight after
the interview they come in and then
so i'm like the first point of contact
with some guys and i'm like
okay so what brought you here and
they're like my mom made me come here
and i say straight away i'm like if your
mum made you come here you're not gonna
you're not gonna change and this
program's gonna get a lot harder like
you have to want to be here
you can't come you can't do rehab you
can't get clean for a spouse for
you know i think it's a driving motor it
can drive you but at the end it's not
going to be enough because when it gets
tough and when it gets
when things start coming up that you
haven't worked through
if you don't really want the change it's
not going to work like you can do it for
your children which
i think is amazing but they really need
to change for themselves
to be better for the children not like
so
as far as people wanting to yeah i wish
i could
some days i almost want to come and
adopt people in a van and just bring
them in
i know that's that's almost like i
talked to a company just come in the
middle of the night with a team
well i spoke to a police officer
yesterday about a 5150 yeah i've heard
about it because i've been talking
with uh uh one of the guys i interviewed
his name is paul blond guy
white guy who's on crystal man oh yeah
with the show he had the shitless yeah
yeah and his mom reached out to me so
i've been speaking with his mom
trying to find him trying to find him so
this week i found him wow
and i'm like this is great and she wants
to put him up in hotel and then she's
gonna fly out and and make him all
better and he's all gonna be great
except i saw him on the street and he
you know he trusts me he's been here
several times but yeah
i started i told him that i was in
contact with his mom and he just
thought that was odd yeah and i told him
that he she'd like to help him and
can i put you up in a hotel or something
so that his mom could hop on a plane and
come out here
and he just started talking some
gibberish and walked off and yeah it was
like it was very clear to me that
i don't think any a pack of wild horses
could get him to do anything yeah
other than just hang out in the street
and yeah find his drug
yeah it's i think i've read a comment
that you wrote about
people possibly getting arrested which
is what i yeah i think about that as
well
that's why i'm speaking with the police
officer about 5150 i said what i mean
because even paul's mom was suggesting
that and and he said you can't really
do that to people unless they are
clearly
i mean they're they're all hurting
themselves yeah but he says
it's got to be like they're it's
life-threatening yeah and otherwise
it won't stick and it's the person i'd
say it's pretty life-threatening
yeah i know but but yeah he says it
doesn't really work yeah the way you're
thinking it or
oh this is yeah put them away into the
wall because i've always had that i'm
like
like for chase you know so heroin is the
worst one because people are scared
to detox and the detoxes are all full at
least the ones that people tell me about
so when i our program is straight cold
turkey so it's no cigarettes no alcohol
it's nothing like you have caffeine
that's about it but
so when i get anyone who wants help and
they're on heroin
they they freak out and they can't do it
i had to do this week he was kicking
heroin he did
five days you know irritated angry
cussing me out all kinds of stuff and
then we actually fully he actually
kicked it but
he wanted to go to another program but i
was like hey if we can help someone for
six days
that's fine but people yeah people have
to want
who have to want to do it and people
have well have free will
so it is what it is and i really think
people have to really hit rock bottom
for them
to want to get help like something
which i don't know like if you know how
we see them out there you think that's
rock bottom
so i don't know what rock bottom is for
them but people really have to hit rock
bottom and really get sick and tired of
that you know the tents moving and the
cops messing with them and
you know if it's a woman that most of
the time they're getting there's a man
around here that's messing with them
yeah and owns them and stuff but what
do you what do you and certainly there's
there's everyone's an individual and
they all have different stories some
people come from backgrounds like yours
and mine which is pretty straight but
they end up
addicted to crack or quote yeah and
other ones have
terrible traumatic childhoods that are
they're trying to numb out from
yeah what do you what do you think the
root cause of a lot of these
situations is people trying to fill
something
so whether it's like you said with
people even good having good
upbringings there's still something
there
that they're missing so for them it
could be
you know they might have had a normal
upbringing with two parents but they
never felt
love or they had parents who were too
strict so they never got to do drugs so
there's always that curiosity and then
with the people who have
had terrible brains they're just yeah
they're just trying to numb the pain and
forget about things that have happened
which
which is terrible because that's the
common thing and then
when you hear their upbringings and it's
just it's it breaks my heart and it's
terrible
it's just you wouldn't wish that upon
anyone but
with mental health services and it's
like there's a com i think there's a
combination of two
mental health and drug addiction and
either people will do drugs
without mental health and then develop
mental health or they'll have mental
health and then
use drugs and then that's the one that
creates
the mental health issues and the drug
addiction is what really i think that's
when people
yeah that's when i don't even know what
it is yeah i could title every
video on my channel um mental mentally
ill
yeah personally yeah because that
applies to every single one of them but
yeah that would get redundant and boring
and i don't think i'd get that many
people coming to my channel
so i title it you know yeah crystal meth
addict or
prostitute or pimp or whatever but it
all boils down to some mental health
issues
yeah i mean i think what
what i keep hearing over and over and
over again is it's a lack of
unconditional love
yeah as a child yeah because because
what a lot of people call love like from
a parent
yeah actually wasn't unconditional love
so it's almost something that's
disguised as that
so you think that's love but it actually
wasn't yeah
and that's almost worse than not having
it at all yeah
and that's how i hear a lot of these
stories i'm like man you came from what
sounds like a good childhood yeah
but that integral part of yeah if you
dig a little deeper it'd be like
it looks good on paper yeah you know two
parents and we
middle class but almost that can
sometimes almost be the worst one
because
there's no like it's not clear no
connection with
you know what i mean like the parents
might be busy with work and the kids
just
never feel like they've been any kind of
relationship with their parents and
it's funny that you say unconditional
love because that's something that i'm
trying to work on right now with people
i really
struggle with i come down here and i can
love on these people
go inside tents sit inside tents you
know talk to people for 45 minutes
but then sometimes with people in my own
circle i struggle
because they're not you know what i mean
it's like i know yeah so i think every
single human
man it's a hard thing and i'd say yeah
trauma so whether it's a minor trauma
from something like that or
trauma from you know being sexually
abused or things like that it's being
bullied
yeah being bullied yeah with ronnie like
ronnie i know i know ronnie
brooke who's like one of my best friends
who i was just with before i came down
she's in contact with ronnie's mom and
all kinds of stuff so we're trying to
sort that out because she legitimately
sees ronnie and she's like like i could
be friends with this girl like i could
be
like she's not just i met her wow she's
amazing like i see her being like a part
of my like helping her out of this
you know i there's there's a billion
comments like that ronnie's amazing
players i can't
i can't put these viewers in contact
because eventually somebody's gonna be a
stalker
yeah and that gets somebody into trouble
i don't want any part of that yeah so
it's mainly just
yeah minor it could be minor trauma or
major trauma but there's some kind of
thing that people have never dealt with
so they're trying to fulfill it or
satisfy themselves in drugs or
prostitution and because that's you know
acceptance of other whatever it is but
i think that's it's all just trauma
yeah yeah i mean people look at my
channel i think oh it's an addiction
schedule channel and it clearly is
to me it's not and over the next year
it'll become very clear that it's not
but if anything
what i'm doing is a unconditional love
channel yeah
because to me that's exactly that's what
these stories are all about
the lack of that sends a person yeah
it's a person like
just off this off the rails yeah it does
yeah
so what's your background you came from
australia came from so
grew up in sydney australia your family
was together
yeah together yeah i grew up my parents
are sort of they just celebrated 30
years
last week that's great yeah middle child
i got two sisters which was
just great i love them you know
me against the world being the boy yeah
the middle child there's always a
special guy yeah and we lived in
australia until we were 10.
then we moved to atlanta georgia for
three years then we moved
here to la for two years and then moved
back to australia in 2009 and then i
came back out here in january
2019 to help out at the dream center
because when we lived in la
2007 2008 we were involved so it was
something that had a pretty big impact
on my family and
when my life went off the rails a little
bit i knew that was a place i could come
back because i need to get out of this i
was done with this trailer i just got to
get out of here
kind of throw the smoke bombs and
disappear
which has been for a little bit longer
than what i've said so do you have a
history of some
issues as well yeah i had some like
mental health issues uh
2018 i
got diagnosed with like depression and
was kind of having suicidal
thoughts and tendencies for a good six
months
which uh we only just met but i'm i'm
more i'm a very
out there person so for someone who'd
never dealt with feelings of
low before like i didn't know it was
almost like extreme because i know how
to deal with it because i'm such a
person that's usually high
and up and always having a good time and
joyous and then when you
realize that people expecting you to be
like that it kind of and working in the
industry i was working as a
personal trainer so no one wants a
depressed personal trainer
they want someone who's going to
encourage them so you know i had to put
it was very
like draining trying to put on an act
yeah for those six months and then um
yeah realize that to come back what do
you think the culprit was and you're a
problem
well i had on my eggs all in one basket
so what i thought was my purpose and
you know my calling or whatever i was
gonna do in life was all gone once i got
ripped away i had no
backup plan and then yeah i'd say that i
would say
having my dr what i thought my dream was
kind of ripped out from underneath me
yeah
yeah well i think helping others to give
active
giving to others yeah yeah
has some kind of magical it does affect
you yeah like pop matthew bunnett the
pastor of the dream center always says
if you're in a rut or you're feeling you
know depressed and down he's like go and
serve others
and it'll bring you it's not like a
quick fit like not to like heal it but
you'll just realize that helping people
are in a worse situation than you which
is like what happened for me the first
time i came down here i was like
well my life's not that bad i lived in a
house my whole life i had
two parents who were awesome you know
i've got
food i've got clothes i've got this and
you know i met a dude named you know
bart who stays young
young white dude who stays across from
whitney he's always running around
riding a bike he's got blown hair who's
the first
the first thing i've met he's a year
older than me and i was just like
what are you doing down here and he was
like i didn't even he couldn't even
answer it
i think anyone had asked him what he was
doing down here and he was like i don't
know and that just blew me away and i
was like
i i think the the tendency to be
um a little like
self-conscious self-obsessed all that
kind of stuff that a lot of
you see you see in regular society all
the time
um who's a comedian in saturday live she
does the sarah palin
oh tina tina made a comment once i
thought was
was great about about this yeah
and she says uh mother teresa never
worries about her thighs touching
ah yeah you know she's always helping
people yeah yeah and she feels great
about herself
yeah regardless of how she's looking
that day or how her
skin or hair would ever look she's yeah
you know and i think there's
a lot of truth in that yeah definitely
like
i think you come down here and you
realize how much you actually do have
without knowing
like it's almost like a
it really threw me off because i was
like wow i just feel like a real
sense of conviction and feeling great
and grateful for my life and yep
and then this is like skid row and then
you know i haven't been to third world
countries but this is
i mean great gratitude is a hard thing
to just you know everybody says oh we
should have more gratitude yeah
that that sounds good on paper yeah but
how do you actually do it
yeah and i found by you know i believe
i'm helping someone yeah and i've heard
it
a thousand times but i've also heard
that i'm exploiting people and all this
other stuff which i don't buy but
but but there's some truth in that yeah
you know when uh
how do you i mean what's the best
analogy i mean when uh when a wealthy
man
attractive female marries a wealthy man
is she doing it because
of the security he'll provide or is it
because it's true love yeah
there's probably a little bit of both
and when a man buys a uh
expensive sports car because he
appreciates fine automobiles or is it
because he feels insecure
it's a little bit of both it's always a
little bit of both yeah and so am i
exploiting people yes of course i'm
exploiting people but
but every single person i didn't course
or trick or yeah
manipulate them into coming in i said
would you like to do this and very often
i
even forget to mention that there's
money involved yeah and then they find
out that there is and oh that's great i
didn't realize they get paid
and so on the one hand yes i'm sure
if you look at it negatively i'm
exploiting them but yeah but in a
positive light i think
i'm helping them to unload a lot of
their yeah hidden closeted
garbage that that yeah is just unraveled
they're wearing it every day
of their lives and i've heard from
several people that i've talked to that
said they're they've stopped using since
they had a talk
in front of me so it's amazing so that's
interesting but uh
i'm not saying i'm healing anything i
think just unloading their their
it's always like as much as you want i
think like as much as you want someone
to hear you you know what's your story
these you don't think these people want
you know
people to know their story and know how
their day's going i think it's just like
that's where
because i know we don't have a lot of
homeless people in australia and then so
my mindset was kind of stereotype-based
when i came here and then i just
realized i was like
they're just people flesh bone you know
they're human exactly the same as me
they check out and it's just like
you know they have feelings i'm sure
they know that
yeah they're here and it's just hearing
that yeah i would just encourage like
go talk to a homeless person go find
their story and
find what they need it's just give you a
good sense of
yeah where you're at and what you have
and then you'd probably cherish it a
little bit more and
walk around with a little more sense of
gratitude i'd say yeah
yeah i've never been happier since i've
started doing this yeah
yeah this like healed my not because i'm
helping people because i just realized
that hey my life's pretty good and
like depression i can be in the worst
mood and i come down here and i'm like
wow yeah is that so much that i'm
comparing my life to their their poor
miserable lives but
there's something about what i'm doing
that makes me
feel better about myself and that that
bleeds into every aspect of my life from
the way i sleep to the
to everything yeah yeah you just you
just stand up straighter and you feel
better about yourself you can go to bed
knowing that hey
kind of helped i did something today
that helped someone you know yeah yeah
i think just one yeah i've had countless
people
yeah i've talked to i think 1300 people
now wow and i've
seen i can't even count how many people
have come back and said oh my god that
was so great i wanna do that again
wow they almost all do that almost
everybody i speak to if i see them again
like can i do that again
that's amazing and it's like yeah so i
think there's something very therapeutic
about definitely you know
getting your stuff out in the in the
light of day letting everybody hear it
at least in theory on youtube you're
talking to the entire planet
in theory right yeah and there's very
something very powerful in that
definitely and it uh it frees you up to
it it keeps you from being locked into
doing the same
defensive mechanism behaviors that you
always do and you you're free to do
otherwise yeah if you choose to
it just takes a little bit of courage to
do that yeah yeah she says yeah
yeah take a bit of a courage to go walk
up to because i
remember i was scared of him as we was a
kid we went to new york city once
and you know in the well i know the
courage is not an issue for me but yeah
good courage for them to
unload these things that they they oh
yeah yeah sorry that's what i'm talking
about yeah it definitely
i mean it takes a lot of correction
takes a lot of courage yeah yeah because
you'll get people
who ask hey what's your story and i see
it and they i can see the
you can see them trying to process it of
like oh no i can't bring that up or
i don't trust this person and then you
know i might be times where i've come
down and then
might be the fourth time that person
finally opens up and then we're able to
actually be like
okay you know now we can help now we can
what do you need you need
shoes or you need this we have the
program we have
you know it's just until they yeah you
know until they open up and they
want the help it's kind of yeah same
with addiction or
whether they need services or whatever
it's just yeah i think what you what the
dream center is providing is
is a it's it's it's what every person
down here needs but they also have to
want it yeah they have to want it yeah
all right hayden well thank you so much
for talking to me thank you and good
luck with everything you're doing
i'm i'm proud of you yeah thank you man
the world needs more people like you
thank you
thank you very much all right thank you
wow
that was cool yeah and you're wearing
the right colored shirt from my
background oh yeah
it was perfect couldn't have done better
we had many shirts no you like my
wardrobe